America is opening up relations with
Cuba and it's a big deal ending decades
of hostility and beginning a new era
between the two countries but to
understand just how big of a deal where
that hostility really came from why it
took so long to end you've got to go
back way back not to the 1950s as many
Americans might think but to the 1850s
the story starts with America divided
between pro-slavery and anti-slavery
politics and one of the many fights is
over the Spanish colony of Cuba
pro-slavery lawmakers want to buy Cuba
from Spain
or take it by force to turn it into a
new slave state anti-slavery politicians
oppose this calling it imperialism but
fast forward to 1898 after slavery is
over
Americans have a different version of
this same argument when Cubans rise up
against Spain the u.s. joins them
starting the spanish-american war but
Americans divided should the u.s. seize
Cuba from Spain for itself were liberate
the island this is part of a much bigger
debate at the time over whether the US
should explicitly become a
european-style imperial power so this is
an argument about Cuba but it's also an
argument about America what kind of
country it should be should America be
the kind of country that controls Cuba
or that respects it as a fellow
sovereign nation and that argument has
continued in different forms
ever since at this point in 1898 the
fight happens in Congress each side
passes laws trying to force their way
and it ends up with a weird split baby
policy with Cuba winning independence
but other quasi imperial American rule
the US would take over Guantanamo Bay
dictate Cuba's foreign policy and give
itself the right to intervene in Cuban
affairs
then came the American interventions in
Cuba in 1906 1917 each time the US
military takes over for a few years
ostensibly to resolve some political
crisis but that usually means protecting
American interests such as sugar imports
today when Americans think about the
u.s. and Cuba we think of the Cold War
the Cubans often think back to this
Imperial era now that era technically
ends in 1933 with an uprising against
Cuba's government under US law America's
supposed to intervene again but
President Franklin Roosevelt wants to
end the Imperial era so he declares
neutrality over the next 20 years
Cuba becomes a democracy and one that's
generally friendly with the US that
changes in 1952 when a former president
and military leader named Valencia
Batista seizes power and a coup suspends
the Constitution and imposes
increasingly oppressive rule Cuba's
communist uprising begins the next year
led by a young Fidel Castro American
politics at this point is obsessed with
fears of communism so the u.s. backs
Batista in the war no matter how brutal
he becomes for Americans this feels like
a front in the struggle against
communism but for Cubans it feels like
Batista is an extension of American
imperialism and the guerrilla war a
continuation of their long fight for
freedom and the Communists win in 1959
and Castro takes power the u.s. fearing
communism expansion sets up the embargo
to strangle Cuba's economy tries to
assassinate Castro and even in the
disaster known as Bay of Pigs sends in
CIA trained Cubans to try to take over
the island Castro turns to the Soviets
for health and in 1962 they nearly start
World War 3
when the u.s. blocks Soviet efforts to
put nuclear missiles in Cuba the
incident scares everyone enough that
things settle into a tense but basically
peaceful status quo
over time ordinary Cubans are squeezed
between the US embargo and Castro's
dictatorship in 1980 Castro tries to
relieve some political dissent by
briefly allowing Cubans to leave the
island and 125,000 arrived in Florida no
one realizes it at the time but this
adds a completely new dimension to the
conflict it's now also about the
internal Cuban battle between Castro
versus Cuban dissidents which plays out
through American politics now this
becomes really important in the 1990s
after the Soviet Union collapses
President Bill Clinton seen Cuba poses
no threat wants to end the conflict as
soon as Castro can't count on Soviet aid
anymore
the Cubans in America who suffered
terribly Castro's hand want to see him
fall and push for keeping the embargo in
the middle of his fight in 1996 Cuba
shoots down two private planes chartered
by Cuban American activists there's a
big backlash in the US and Clinton backs
down 20 years later President Barack
Obama tries again to end the conflict by
now Americans don't really support the
embargo lots of Cuban Americans are now
economic migrants rather than political
exiles so they whent openness the Fidel
is getting old and in 2008 hands power
to his brother Raul who knows the
country needs to change the u.s. and
Cuba starts secret talks in 2013 the new
Pope Francis helps negotiate in 2014
they reveal their agreement to end the
conflict and the next year Obama becomes
the first president to visit since
Calvin Coolidge in 1928 in the u.s. and
Cuba I've never really had normal
relations until now and that's crucial
to understanding why it took so long for
this to happen so much has passed
between the two countries over the past
century and the u.s. has at times
treated Cuba is more of a colony than
its real country it's a lot to get over
but it looks like they might both
finally be ready